[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire de ce
journal nous reviendrons sur la
poursuite des blocage par les
agriculteurs que ce soit à Paris à Lyon
et toujours en province bien sûr nous
nous rendrons à bovv sur l'autoroute A16
avec notre partenaire o TV et puis nous
évoquerons la problématique juridique
posée par ce que l'on appelle les colold
case avec le cas du meurtre de Marie-
Thérèse beauanti survenu il y a 27 ans
dans la région de Grenoble son meurtrier
malgré ses aveux ne sera pas poursuivi
en raison et oui de la prescription des
faits nous y reviendrons avec
téléGrenoble la meilleur apprenti
cuisinier de France est une troisenne et
étudie au CFA doser elle a tou juste 19
ans une équipe de Canal 32 a accompagné
Lily Rose Martens c'est son nom dans son
quotidien de futur chef vous verrez
enfin nous irons avec notre partenaire
TBO en Bretagne à la rencontre de cette
entreprise d'insertion qui a développé
une bouée de sauvetage qui équipe les
navigateurs en solitaire engagés sur
l'arquea ultime
challenge et puis pour commencer ce
journal malgré les annonces du Premier
ministre la colère des agriculteurs ne
faiblit pas plusieurs centaines de
tracteurs ont convergé vers Paris et
Lyon provoquant de grands blocages sur
plusieurs axes routiers et aussi pour
l'accès au marché de ringis en province
aussi l'action des agriculteurs se
poursuit comme l'a constaté Jérôme
moubron sur l'autoroute à 16 à beauvet
pour notre partenaire o TV la chaîne de
la voie du Nord sur une autoroute
déserte le bivoac retrouve peu à peu son
calme tu penses ça va tenir
ça 120 tracteurs viennent de quitter les
lieux en direction de de la capitale pas
de répis pour les quelques agriculteurs
restés sur
place là il y a donc le rangement à
faire puis après repréparer le repas
pour ce soir et puis ouais du du du
ménage du ménage quoi c'est du boulot en
fait c'est du boulot beaucoup de boulot
ouais depuis maintenant une semaine près
de 200 personnes se relent ici nuit et
jour pour assurer le blocage de
l'autoroute A16 près de bvet quand vient
le soir certains rentrent chez eux
d'autres optent pour un lit de fortune
comme cette bétaillère des conditions
preuve d'une volonté
inébranlable c'est pas c'est pas ce
qu'il y a de plus évident c'est pas ce
qu'on préfère on préférerait être dans
notre lit au chaud avec nos femmes nos
enfants mais mais malheureusement ben il
faut il y a pas le choix si on veut
tenir le mouvement c'est pas que partir
la journée avec les tracteurs c'est
aussi être là la nuit pour tenir le camp
une organisation rigoureuse où tout doit
être pensé exemple avec l'eau potable
ressources indispensabl mise à
disposition par l'un des agriculteurs
c'est une grosse intendance et il en
faut pour la vaisselle pour la boisson
pour pour un peu tout tout quoi celle-ci
elle vient d'où là elle vient de la
ferme c'est la même eau qu'on donne aux
bêtes de l'eau mais aussi de quoi
assurer les repas chaque jour pain
fruits viandes ou même légumes des
produits issus des organisations
professionnelles agricoles ou bien donné
par celles et ceux qui soutiennent à
leur façon le mouvement dans tous les
cas un carburant pour le moral faut
rester soudé faut rester mobilisé et
ensemble on est plus fort ce siège les
agriculteurs disent pouvoir le tenir une
semaine de plus d'autres actions
prendront forme comme à Amien où les
rassemblements débuteront à
9h voilà et puis la grogne agricole se
propage à d'autres corps de métier il en
V ai des chauffeurs de taxi qui
s'étaient donné rendez-vous lundi à
l'aube devant le stade de Bordeaux près
d'un millier d'entre eux ont mené une
opération de blocage de la circulation
sur la rocade bordelaise des taxis
girondin mais aussi de cinq départements
voisins venus protester contre la
nouvelle convention qui les lie aux
caisses primaires d'assurance maladie un
sujet d'Alix Fourcade pour TV7 la chaîne
du groupe
sud-ouest Michel et chemendy a fait 3h
de route pour arriver au point de
rassemblement des taxis à 7h devant le
stade Matmut Atlantique à Bordeaux
pourquoi vous avez fait la route depuis
Cambo jusqu'ici mais c'est juste pour
défendre no de droit au travail et pour
notre nouvelle convention de CQ qui
veulent nous imposer comme lui ils sont
plusieurs centaines de conducteurs de
taxi de la région à s'être donné
rendez-vous pour mener une opération
escargot toute la matinée sur la rocade
bordelaise leur but protester contre
leur nouvelle convention qui les lie à
l'assurance maladie et qui risque de
réduire leur revenus pour les transports
médicaux on est ici parce que la CPM
nationale à de Paris a décidé sans nous
concerter de nous faire faire des
remises sur nos augmentations
préfectorales et en plus de renégocier
la remise que l'on fait déjà sur les
transports médicaux actuellement et
benah on sait pas où on va on a bientôt
peur de plus pouvoir vivre correctement
de notre métier on a des patients qui
nous appellent tous les jours on sait
pas dans quelles conditions on va
pouvoir les transporter donc voilà à
force de de pas avoir descûes et ben on
est obligé de faire des des des blocages
comme comme aujourd'hui avant leur
départ les conducteurs ont distribué des
tractes au passants plutôt rattaché à
leur cause je suis moi-même agriculteur
vous savez donc avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en France c'est quand même
difficile de gagner sa vie vous les
soutenez bien sûr que je les soutiens
pour quelle raison les taxis et les les
agriculteurs ils ont bien raison ça
suffit maintenant à 8h le convoi a
démarré et s'est divisé en deux groupes
pour investir les rocades intérieur et
extérieur ils doivent être reçus à 15h à
la préfecture de la
Géronde tout à fait autre chose de
nombreux crimes ne trouvent pas leur
solution après de nombreuses années
c'est ce qui a conduit à la création du
pôle judiciaire des crimes non élucidé
un pôle qui se heurte parfois à la loi
sur la prescription il en est ainsi de
la décision de la chambre de
l'instruction de la cour d'appel de
Grenoble qui a confirmé la remise en
liberté d'Iv chatin ce dernier qui a
reconnu le meurtre de Marie- Thérèse
Bonfanti en 1986 à pontchara a pu sortir
de la prison la semaine dernière
incroyable regardez ce reportage de
Mirko peci pour téléGrenoble le 22 mai
1986 à pontchara Marie- Thérèse bfanti
une jeune mère de 25 ans disparaît alors
qu'elle distribuait le journal sa
voiture est retrouvée devant une maison
clé sur le contact à l'époque le
propriétaire des lieux Yve chatin est
soupsonné interrogé puis relâché
l'affaire est classée en non lieu 2 ans
plus tard la famille n'a jamais lâché
prise et elle a toujours pensé que y
chatin pouvait être lié à la disparition
de Marie- Thérèse Bonfanti donc ils ont
mené leur propre enquête ça a duré aussi
des années ils ont donné le résultat de
leur travail au procureur de la
République quic vaillant qui a missionné
la gendarmerie nationale pour relancer
également cette procédure en 2022 Yv
chatin est placé en garde à vue il avoue
son meurtre et dévoile le lieu où est
enterré le corps mais le 28 novembre
2023 37 ans après le crime la Cour de
cassation a estimé que les fait était
prescrit aujourd'hui on est vraiment
dépité on comprend pas cette décision
qui est vraiment
une décision décourageante et qui n'est
pas courageuse de la part de de la Cour
de cassation je pense pas que c'est un
un bon renvoi à la population
d'avoir donné ce compte-rendu pour nous
c'est difficile d'entendre qu'il a qu'il
y a prescription dans notre dans notre
affaire parce que tout était caché
jusqu'au corps de notre maman il a été
caché là avec cette
prescription
bah du coup ben il pour sortir libre et
en plus blanchi par la par la loi c'est
incompréhensible aujourd'hui accompagné
de leur avocat la famille de la victime
a participé à une conférence sur l'école
case en présence de Jacques d'alest à
l'origine du pôle spécialisé de Nan le
débat c'est de savoir si le fait que
l'auteur des faits du crime a dissimulé
le corps constitue un obstacle qui a
permis de suspendre la prescription
c'estàdire de considérer c'est le jour
où il révèle l'affaire que la
prescription court c'est un vrai débat
parce que la famille a du mal à
comprendre qu'on ne puisse pas juger
quelqu'un qui a commis un crime le
dossier sera réexaminé par la chambre de
l'instruction de la cour d'appel de Lyon
courant
2024 voilà et puis autre chose dans
l'actualité de nouvelles réductions de
services lié à l'ouverture de travaux
sur la ligne Paris- Orléan limoge
Toulouse provoque un véritable ralbol
général entre Paris Orléan limog
Toulouse tout au long de cette ligne
ferroviaire la nostalgie du Capitol
demeure ce train de grande ligne relié
Paris à limoge en environ 2h50 jusque
dans les années 80 aujourd'hui compté
3h20 des annulations à non plus finir
des pannes quasi cootidienne et un
matériel totalement à bout de souffle
pour cet allimoge Alain Druot a arpenté
la salle des pas perdus de la garde des
bénédicttin à l'écoute de passagers et
d'élus qui réclamament une vraie prise
en compte de leur difficultés dans la
tion entre les territoires sur la ligne
Paris Orléan limoge Toulouse les
rassemblements se succèdent depuis
plusieurs années des classement abandon
casse du service rendu au public les
usagers syndicats et élus sont sur la
même longueur d'onde les promesses de
milliards qu'on a en ce moment c'est
c'est des choses qui vont se voir dans 5
ou 10 ans donc ce sera plus le même
ministre et en fait on nous réannonce
des milliards des milliards des
milliards sur la ligne les travaux qu'il
y a qui commencent la semaine prochaine
important là c'est des choses qui ont
été décidé avant que Clément bon soit
min ça met l'imoge à l'écart en fait de
ce qui doit être l'avenir de notre de
notre territoire tous les élus et
clairement avec nous des annonces en
travaux en nouveau matériel fixe un
objectif de retour à un service décent
en 2026 de années de travaux commencent
dès à présent avec un service encore
plus dégradé temps de parcours et
fréquences vont être malmené il faut
croire à cet objectif mais on est uni
pour surveiller SNCF et gouvernement
pour que l'objectif de 2026 ne soit pas
repoussé au 4 grec faut que l'on se
batte pour que les engagements pris
soient soient tenus ce n'est que dans le
collectif que nous y arriverons le
service qui est supposé être rendu pour
195 € n'est pas rendu donc ça confine
presque à l'escroquerie maintenant alors
une fois un incident ça s'entend deux
fois ça peut se comprendre mais tous les
jours de manière récurrente c'està
direire que si aujourd'hui le train est
plus en panne c'est presque une anomalie
SNCF a mal joué en disant bah on va
faire tenir notre matériel jusqu'au
prochain sauf que ça tient pas et puis
l'État joue pas non plus son rôle
puisque c'est l'État qui est l'autorité
organisatrice de transport pour les
interciétés il y a fort à Paris et que
d'autres rassemblements ralpolt vont se
tenir dans les prochains mois la
nostalgie du capital demeure et
l'ensemble des participants espère le
retour de la fiabilité du service sur la
ligne Saint-Christophe sera convoqué les
pratiquants ferroviaire devront
reprendre le
train voilà à 19 ans elle remporte le
concours de Meilleur apprentis cuisiners
de France ouvrons maintenant une page
gastronomique dans ce journal pour
adresser toutes nos félicitations à Lily
Rose Marens car à 19 ans la jeune femme
a remporté le concours de Meilleur
apprentis cuisiners elle n'est que la 4e
femme à inscrire son nom au palmarès
presque exclusivement masculin de cette
épreuve si convoité qui compte 69
lauréas elle a aussi pour elle d'avoir
réussi son cap en seulement 1 an contre
deux habituellement Lili Rose est donc
une surdouée de la cuisine comme l'a
constaté canal 32 sur place regardez à
19 ans Lili Rose Martins a remporté le
titre de meilleur apprenti cuisinier de
France lors de l'épreuve nationale qui a
réuni les 13 meilleurs candidats
régionaux ça m'a changé parce que j'ai
appris à gérer mon stress même s'il y en
a toujours encore un peu après là déjà
je vais pouvoir faire un stage à
l'Élysée c'est la preuve qu'avec un cap
on peut faire de grandes choses que
c'est pas forcément une voix pour les
personnes qui savent pas trop quoi faire
après l'obtention de son bac avec plus
de 17 de moyenne et une mention Très
Bien Lily Rose a choisi de se réorienter
vers sa première passion en visant
l'excellence ça m'a un peu surpris mais
pas très longtemps parce que depuis
l'âge de de 9 10 ans elle venait déjà
avec moi elle montait sur un saut à
décorer les donuts celle l'a toujours
beaucoup plus je m'attendais pas à ce
qu'elle gagne le titre parce qu'il y a
quand même de de très grandes maisons
qui sont là le deuxième c'est quand même
l'apprenti de chez Anne Sophie Pic et
puis il y avait d'autres étoilet et
Michelin donc il avait du lourd derrière
les portes des 250 restaurants
gastronomiques s'ouvrent à elle
l'épreuve du concours lui a permis de
cuisiner des plats de chef avec le
soutien d'un coach donc mon rôle à moi à
partir du moment où on était qualifié
pour la finale c'est de l'emmener près
le jour J c'est l'équivalent d'être
meilleur ouvrier de France chez les
apprentis et sauf qu'il y en a qu'un à
partir des fiches techniques des
recettes elle s'est entraînée durant 2
mois avec le soutien de son entourage
har forge lui a confectionné ses
porte-pièces son restaurant du temps
pour s'exercer il y a vraiment une
notion de transmission et bien sûr que
pour li quand on a su qu'elle était
qu'elle rentré dans dans ce concours là
moi je lu donné carte blanche j'aime
bien dans la cuisine c'est justement
qu'il y a pas trop de limite il y a des
recettes que j'aime bien des des plat
traditionnel que j'aime bien mais j'aime
bien aussi l'innovation la cuisine
molléculaire je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant Lili Rose Martins a choisi
de prolonger son CP en entamant une
année de formation dans la réalisation
de desserts pour restaurant
le chef étoilé Jérôme Nutile installé à
nî ne conçoit pas son métier sans de
fortes valeur de partage et d'humanité
c'est la raison pour laquelle il
organise chaque semaine avec le secours
catholique du gare des ateliers de
cuisine pour ses bénéficiaires en
précarité pour via occitan Olivier
Michal a participé à ce moment d'une
grande convivialité durant lequel le
meilleur ouvrier de France 2011 a ouvert
ses cuisines et a élaboré avec eux le
repas de midi regardez
courge poireau marron c'est autour des
légumes et fruits du moment que le chef
étoilé Jérôme Nutile a concocté son menu
du jour on va faire un veloué de
courge avec des éclats de châne je vais
mettre et une crème à la truffe après il
y aura de la de la volaille qu'on va
faire la crème de fois gras avec une
purée de pomme de terre et puis une
brioche perdue avec des ananas rôti
glace vanille et couli caramel de sa
brigade elle est aujourd'hui constituée
de bénévoles et de bénéficiire de l'aide
du Secours Catholique un geste de
solidarité penser à la lecture du
dernier rapport annuel sur l'état de la
pauvreté en France qui alerte sur la
situation catastrophique de certaines
femmes de plus en plus nombreuses à
tomber dans la précarité c'est un public
qui est soit en situation de de
précarité financière soit qui vivent des
situations
d'isolement l'objectif de pouvoir les
réunir aujourd'hui c'est de de créer du
lien de pouvoir venir découvrir de
nouvelles méthodes de cuisiner mais
surtout de passer un moment convivial ah
tu as du mal mal autour du chef et de
ses dosages de beurre de sel de vin
blanc ou de RH les questions fusent et
des langues se dénouent parce que moi
qui en général suis un peu timide et
tout j'ose pas trop et ben là je
commence à voilà à comprendre on apprend
des choses on voit d'autres façons de
faire plus fines plus différente un
temps de convivialité é pensé par le
chef avec la volonté de les sortir de
leur quotidien au terme de la matinée
les convives ont été invités à passer à
table histoire de savourer leur propre
m voilà et puis depuis la fermeture en
2023 du dernier bar épicerie les
habitants de Saint-Bonnet le Courau dans
la Loire n'ont plus qu'une seule
boulangerie pour satisfaire leurs
besoins pour y remédier la commune a
décidé d'investir 700000 € dans la
rénovation d'un ancien hôtel restaurant
fermé depuis presque 20 ans elle ESP à
s'y recréer un lieu de vie et offrir un
service à sa population écoutons les
explications de Joël épin maire de
saint-bonet le courourau au micro de TL7
dans la Loire l'idée c'est de que le
gérant investisse à minima dans le
bâtiment la commune pour tout ce qui est
infrastructure appartement le gérant
aura à investir au niveau de de la
cuisine et de du mobilier mais par
contre derrière nous on aura un loyer
très modéré euh 300 € par mois pour que
le la personne puisse développer son son
entreprise voilà et puis du côté des
territoires d'outremer en Martinique les
jeunes arlaésiens habitant le village de
pêcheurs de l'aisance d'arley vivent une
expérience originale en pratiquant
l'anglais sur le terrain une vingtaine
d'élèves de 3e du collège sont ainsi
aller à la rencontre de touristes pour
un accueil entièrement en anglais à let
you know discover
TV via ATV Martinique avec l'accent s'il
vous plaît
regardez l'accueil de ces touriste se
fait exclusivement en anglais pas
toujours évident d'aborder des étrangers
dans la langue de Shakespeare mais ces
collégiens de 3e et DEA se prêtent
volontiers à l'exercice c'est
déstabilisant de en de parler anglais
parce qu'on n pas l'habitude donc c'est
justement l'exercice qu'on fait on fait
aujourd'hui sert à nous habituer à
l'anglais le fait de parler anglais oui
un petit peu s'acompl c'est un petit peu
compliqué mais on apprend une surprise
pour ces touristes majoritairement
originaire de GrandeBretagne tous
apprécient l'accueil qu' leur réservé et
l'effort fourni par ses jeunes
absolument merveilleux nous avons
visiter de nombreuses îles visiter
toutes les îles au vent et c'est notre
dernière avant de rentrer chez nous à la
Barbade et nous n'avons jamais eu un
accueil comme celui-ci ils sont une
vingtaine d'élèves à s'occuper de la
réception des touristes unjet du collège
alandre St des d'arl ce sont les
professeurs en équipe pédagogique du
collège qui a pensé qu'il fallait
permettre à nos élèves de pratiquer
cette langue vivante en dehors des m de
venir et comme nous sommes une commune
très touristique et ben de d'associer
nos élèves à cet accueil de façon à ce
que le les élèves soient très sensi non
seulement à la pratique de l'importance
de la pratique de l'anglais mais dans
l'accueil des touristes municipalité
harlaisienne et le Comité martiniquain
du Tourisme l'action est à la fois
éducative et promotionnelle c'est un
Paris pour l'avenir pourquoi parce que
nous sommes un territoire touristique et
euh ces activités demandent de de la
main d'œuvre de plus en plus et dans le
cadre de l'insertion professionnelle à
charge pour nous au niveau de la ville
effectivement de faire émerger plus de
jeunes pour s'inscrire et rentrer dans
ces filières là ces jeunes martiniquis
renouvelleront cette opération les 27 et
29 février prochain cette fois à
fort-de-fance puis à Saint-Pierre
elle accompagne les skippperss de
l'arquea ultime challenge dans leur tour
du monde en solitaire elle c'est silzig
une bouette de sauvetage 100 % brestoise
elle est confectionnée dans un atelier
mobilisant des salariés en insertion
professionnelle un reportage d'Alex
caillant sur cette bouée un peu
particulière c'est notre partenaire TBO
la chaîne du groupe le télégram sur
place on a eu la chance de de pouvoir
faire dédicacer la SIL à l'arc ultime
challenge par les six skipers mais bien
avant d'embarquer pour cette course la
bouée avait déjà été utilisée par Jean
Le Cam pour secourir Kevin escoffi en
2020 la silzig a déjà fait ses preuves
l'homme à la mer peut en fait se s'y
accrocher par les deux poignets se
laisser tracter une fois qu'elle est
arrivée près de l'embarcation au plus
près de l'embarcation elle va pouvoir en
fait manipuler la silzig et s'y entourer
et c'est dans cet atelier de Brest que
la boue et fabriqué par des salariés en
insertion au-delà de la production c'est
surtout un moyen pour les personnes de
remettre un pied dans le monde du
travail le plus gros apport qu'on peut
apporter ici c'est la prise de confiance
c'est souvent quand ils arrivent c'est
ce qui leur manque après un accident
Marie-Hélène a passé plusieurs années
sans travailler alors ici elle prend un
réel plaisir à revenir vers l'activité
même si cela demande quelques efforts j'
n'avais aucune
connaissance au niveau Deah tout ce qui
était tout ce qui était machine mais
j'ai appris pas à pas et qui demande un
certain temps pour arriver à ce que ce
soit bien fait parfait la
perfectionexiste pas mais on essaie d'y
arriver au plus les salariés sont
accompagnés entre 6 mois et 2 ans le
temps de se projeter vers un autre
avenir professionnel voilà et puis je
vous signale la reprise de face au
territoire en collaboration avec West
France ce matin Fran Antille le point 20
minutes et géostratégie pour ce premier
numéro nous recevions François Xavier
bami députés européens et vice-président
du parti les républicains il est tête de
liste LR aux élections européennes je
vous propose d'écouter son intervention
dans face au territoire sur TV5 Monde
quand on est tête de liste aux élections
européennes comme vous vouêtes est-ce
qu'on est vraiment maître de la
constitution de sa liste j'ai lu un écho
dans le point il y a quelques jours
disant que vous ne vouliez pas de
geoffroididier un de vos colistiers
possiblebl qui est lui même sortant j'ai
vu qu'au Sénat les sénateurs LR euh vous
avez dit ah on ne veut pas de
brissortefeu de Nanine Morano comment
faites vous et est-ce que vous êtes leur
chef donc vous les suivez comment ça se
passe voà vous savez j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour le travail des journalistes
mais pour le coup ce qui
concerne ces rumeurs que parfois on
trouve colporté deci ou de là ne me
paraît pas ni décisif pour les Français
ni bien souvent correspondre à la
réalité nous nous travaillons avec ti ce
ne sera pas seulement ma décision bien
sûr c'est une décision collective ce
sera la liste de notre famille politique
mais nous travaillons avec un seul
objectif c'est d'être utile aux Français
demain de pouvoir faire en sorte de
peser dans les institutions européennes
de faire que les candidats de cette
liste seront le plus convaincant
possible pour les électeurs pour pouvoir
être demain le plus efficace possible
pour pouvoir servir la voix de la France
au Parlement européen c'est la seule
chose qui compte pour nous voilà et puis
Lucien Magana est luttier depuis près de
30 ans il fabrique des guitares dans son
atelier de de si y en haute de Savoie en
plus de rechercher le son parfait il
s'amuse avec l'esthétique pour faire de
ces instruments des objets uniques
chacun d'entre eux a été fait sur mesure
vous allez le voir ce travail minutieux
nécessite plusieurs heures voire
plusieurs années de la beur pour H
Montblanc Kia Poudou l'a rencontré dans
son atelier
regardez avant d'être lutier Lucien
Magana est surtout passionné par la
musique c'est à l'âge de 13 ans qu'il
découvre la guitare et plus de 60 ans
plus tard cet instrument de musique
détient toujours une place importante
dans sa vie moi je suis chanteur
guitariste donc quand on chante la
guitare c'est un instrument on va dire
presque favori parce qu'on peut
l'emmener partout hein vous assayz coin
d'une table vous prenez une guitare et
puis ça y est c'est parti c'est par
passion qu'il a découvert ce métier dans
les années
1990 ne pouvant pas en vivre à 100 % il
travaillait en parallèle dans une usine
de décolletage aujourd'hui ourd retraité
il continue de créer son instrument
favori au total il a fabriqué près de 80
guitares et voici la pépite de sa
collection celle-elà elle est unique je
l'ai présenté à Paris plusieurs fois et
jusqu'à présent personne ne m'a encore
copié il y a pas d'ouverture il y a une
double table et un double
fond mais avant de pouvoir sortir de T
notes ce prototype lui a demandé
beaucoup de temps plus de 2 ans de
travail les guitares plus traditionnell
elle nécessite quant à elle près de 150
he guitare classique folk électrique ou
encore même des yukouélé sont créé dans
cet atelier sa clientèle étant avant
tout composée de musiciens
professionnels la qualité se doit d'être
irréprochable et cela commence d'abord
par le choix du bois et notamment de la
table d'harmonie élément essentiel de la
guitare puisqu'elle a un énorme rôle à
jouer dans la sonorité de l'instrument
le Picea est un très bon bois de
résonance qui est utilisé depuis
depuis le moyen âge pour fabriquer les
violons les violons sell et cetera le
bois de chacune des parties de la
guitare comme le manche le fond ou
encore les éclies a été réfléchi pour
optimiser ce matériau au maximum suivant
si vous voulez une guitare qui brille ou
une guitare qui soit un peu plus sourde
ou une son qui soit un peu moins
brillant ou un peu plus brillant on
travaille exactement sur les barrages
qui sont sous la table le plus gros de
cette commande surmesure a été effectué
une fois terminée elle ira dans une
salle spéciale dont l'hygrométrie est
mesurée pour permettre à l'instrument
une conservation
optimale voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition du Grand jité des territoires au
revoir à tous à
[Musique]
bientôt